mientras Cuba vive una de sus mayores
crisis económicas también se enfrenta al
preocupante envejecimiento de su
población es el país más envejecido de
América Latina y del Caribe con dos de
cada diez cubanos de al menos 60 años de
edad se explica en parte por el Éxodo
masivo de la población desgraciadamente
y vuelvo a repetir si son jóvenes por
supuesto lo que los que hacen esta tipo
de migración la situación de un avanzado
nivel de crecimiento son las migraciones
y Cuba tiene un saldo migratorio
negativo es decir emigran mucho más que
los pobladores que migran también desde
1930 Y reforzado a partir del año 59
la falta de gente joven representa un
desafío económico ya que menos personas
en edad de trabajar pueden sostener la
actividad económica del país en los
restaurantes de la capital los gerentes
lamentan la falta de personal en este
lapso de 60 trabajadores y hoy por hoy
en Cuba quedan 10 de los 60
es catastrófico el envejecimiento de la
población es también un desafío Social
para la isla ya que debilita el sistema
de seguridad social y salud y podría
poner en peligro a la larga la
financiación del sistema de pensiones
para responder a la situación el
gobierno incentiva a las mujeres a tener
más hijos y busca construir hogares para
ancianos Pero estas medidas solo pueden
ir de la mano con una respuesta a la
crisis económi